i love rap music it's my favorite music
and i love rapping and that's what we're
going to do to kind of close out the
show i'm going to ask did someone just
say oh no and you're like oh
we really liked him and then he had to
go and ruin it no we're going to we're
going to do a freestyle rap that's a
wrap made up on the spot based entirely
on suggestions and so to do it i need
your suggestions you need everyone here
to think up a word a topic or a phrase
you'd like a rap about dark was a
cardiff castle
can someone translate that please
i know where cardiff is it is in wales
cardiff castle boris johnson's been
suggested too many times before so yeah
i know that's
you know can't just call him bojo he's
our [ __ ] leader show some respect
we're not like joe bi you know it's
called [ __ ]
okay bojo whatever
bojo and cardiff castle let's come over
here what'd you guys want to rap about
california escalators okay cool
californian escalators great
let's come to this wedge over here what
would you like a rap about
did you say come on
that's
the thing is it's such a basic
suggestion but i in like i've done this
for i've done 19 years of freestyling um
i don't think anyone ever shouted out a
gig before
come yeah all right
come bojo cardiff castle californian
escalators
i guess i guess middle of the room
you've been neglected
capitalism okay
and elon musk yeah i guess that kind of
that that ties into that doesn't it
the harbinger of our downfall
okay um okay come bojo cardiff castle
elon musk and late stage capitalism and
um californian escalators okay maybe
yeah maybe we'll do it let's just drop a
[ __ ] beat let's let's
let's lay some tracks down let's have
some fun with whatever this is going to
be a rap about
just dial down the bass red you're like
mate it's too it's too late for some
kicking in the stomach base we need to
yeah red noses onions on the keyboards
maybe speed that up a tiny a tidgy tiny
bit right
oh hello oh he's got he's got the steel
drums mate we're getting tropical this
is gonna be nice okay go
we're dropping in upon the beat then
it's off we go number 10 the leader of
the britain land that's the bojo boris
johnson a wrong gun many kids by
different ladies married carrie simmons
lately had a baby she'd be pregnant
arriving soon currently in glasgow like
this afternoon he gave a speech he was
like yo listen you lot he sounds
different to that he was there a cop the
conference of the parties 26 he's like
the climate targets we don't want to
miss you need to respect it i know it's
a hassle he's up in glasgow so they
ain't got a welsh castle that's a
separate part a country south and to the
east if you go and visit there maybe
encounter a weird beast a big red dragon
or maybe daffodils cardiff castle is it
based upon a hill probably it's a
defensive fortification
they sound kind of weird in the welsh
nation they're like oh hello i'm from
cardiff city i can't do it long because
my accent shitty if you go to welsh you
better beware it starts to stray from
wales to india as an accent you know so
we move from swansea and cardiff over
here yeah on the west coast me i'll be
traveling kind of laid back maybe i'll
be smoking out a weed or a bit of crack
and i'm recline right on my back i need
to get up there but my muscles feel
slack so i think i pause and an hour
later i'm like [ __ ] yeah an escalator
why don't i use these grab into the rail
that's really good when your muscles
fail i shall prevail everyone adores i
like to surf there on the shore now i'm
on the third floor [ __ ] how'd it even
work this is great i'm so high oh look
at this my mate he's a surfer dude with
the long hair yeah california
everybody's aware we have fun we'll do
stuff in the day later we like escalate
as [ __ ] elevators they're [ __ ] who even
needs the lift coming over here yeah
it's hard to resist you'll need to
remind me because i'm stoned like the
guy what was the word from here shout it
out so high yeah we got it okay wait
that'll be later the fun just hold it in
the back pocket that be the [ __ ] but i'm
taking this we're gonna have fun i ask
yo elon musk how did you earn your cash
he's like well started companies like
paypal and sold it off and cashed in on
that when it went well and then invested
very clever he brought the electric
automobile and aesthetics together in
tesla people were buying and then the
boring company underground drilling
start trying and what's next spacex may
be to mars and really it's an indictment
of the society of ours that will [ __ ] up
a planet and move to the universe surely
you should try and deal with this [ __ ]
first you start fires earthquakes like a
schism it's a symptom of late stage
capitalism but that's
not as much fun who wants a rap about
that when you could have come come if
you don't know it for some reason it's
just a slang term for a male semen you
put it out there erect and straight come
now i prefer ejaculate it'd be going
there spraying [ __ ] people like
capitalism you say come but i say chism
[Applause]
bye